going to do in this video is try to
evaluate the definite integral from zero
to PI of X cosine of X DX like always
pause this video and see if you can
evaluate it yourself well when you
immediately look at this it's not
obvious how you just straight up take
the antiderivative here and then
evaluate that at PI and then subtract
from that it evaluated at 0 so we're
probably going to have to use a slightly
more sophisticated technique and in
general if you see a product of
functions right over here and if one of
these functions is fairly
straightforward to take the
antiderivative of without making it more
complicated like cosine of X and another
of the functions like X if you were to
take its derivative it gets simpler in
this case it would just become 1 it's a
pretty good sign that we should be using
integration by parts so let's just
remind ourselves about integration by
parts so integration by parts I'll do it
right over here if I have the integral
and I'll just write this as an
indefinite integral but here we want to
take the indefinite integral and then
evaluate at PI and evaluated at 0 so if
I have f of X times G prime of X DX this
is going to be equal to and in other
videos we proved this it really just
comes straight out of the product rule
that you learned in differential
calculus this is going to be equal to f
of X times G of X minus u then swap
these around minus F prime of X G of X
DX and just to reiterate what I said
before you want to find an f of X that
when I take its derivative it simplifies
it so simplify and you want to find a G
prime of X that when I take its
antiderivative so when I take its
antiderivative it doesn't get more
complicated so not more complicated
because if the f of X gets simplified
when I take its derivative and the G
prime of X does not get more complicated
when I take it
anti-derivative then this expression
well maybe be easier to find the
antiderivative of so let's do that over
here between X and cosine of X which one
gets more simple when I take its
derivative well the derivative of X is
just 1 so I'm going to make that my f of
X so I could write that over here so my
f of X I will say is X in which case f
prime of X F prime of X is going to be
equal to 1 and then what would my G
prime of X be well my G prime of X
cosine of X if I take its antiderivative
it doesn't get more complicated the
antiderivative of cosine of X is sine of
X so let me make that my G prime of X so
G prime of X is equal to cosine of X in
which case G of X the antiderivative of
cosine of X well it's just sine of X or
another way to think about it the
derivative of sine of X is cosine of X
now you could think about plus C's and
all of that but remember this is going
to be a definite integral so all the
those arbitrary constants are going to
get cancelled out so now let's think
through this let's just apply the
integration by parts here in this
particular case all of this is going to
be equal to something that is equal to
this I'm going to skip down here it's
going to be equal to f of X times G of X
so that is f of X is X G of X is sine of
X f of X times G of X minus the integral
of F prime of X F prime of X is just 1
we could write like that 1 times G of X
G of X is sine of X so we could write it
like this but 1 times sine of X well we
could just rewrite that as sine of X
it'll make it a little bit simpler sine
of X DX DX and then remember this is a
definite integral so we are going to
want to evaluate this whole thing at PI
and at 0 and then take the difference
between the two but what is the
indefinite integral of sine of X DX well
it were if I were to say the
antiderivative of it we know that the
derivative of
a sine is negative sine of X and so in
fact if we what we want we could bring
this negative sign into the integral so
we can say plus the integral of negative
sine of X now this clearly the
antiderivative here is cosine of X so
this thing is going to be cosine of X
and now we just have to evaluate it at
the endpoints so let's first evaluate
this whole thing at PI so this is going
to be equal to PI sine of pi PI sine of
PI plus cosine of PI and then from that
I'm going to subtract this whole thing
evaluated at zero so let me do zero in a
different color at zero so it's going to
be zero times sine of zero plus cosine
of zero so the sine of pi is just zero
so this is just going to cancel out
cosine of pi that is negative one and
then this is zero and then cosine of
zero that is one so you have negative
one minus one so this all gets us to
negative two and we are done using
integration by parts we were able to
evaluate this definite integral